a nominee for both best supporting and
best actress Oscars this evening welcome
Julianne Moore
when flickers were born they gave birth
to a generation of lip readers who never
heard a movie cowboy with a Hungarian
accent or a sex goddess with a voice
deeper than our leading man's then came
the revolutionary addition of sound for
this milestone year here are the
nominees for achievement in sound
michael Minkler Dominic Tavella and
David Lee Chicago Tom Fleischman Eugene
Garrity and Ivan Chirac a gangster you
Christopher boys
Michael semanek Michael ketches and
Hammond P for the Lord of the Rings the
two towers Scott Nolan Bob BEMER and
John Patrick Pritchett the road to
perdition Kevin O'Connell Greg P Russell
and Ed Nolan for spiders and the Oscar
goes to Michael McClure Dominic Tavella
and David Lee for Chicago
this is Michael Minkler second Academy
Award and his
nomination this is the first Oscar anon
for Dominic - Bella and David Lee
well being a third-generation soundman I
knew at a young age what I wanted to do
in my life and it was when I saw West
Side Story for the first time when I was
really young I thought to myself that's
a goal I want to I want to work on a
picture like that a magnificent musical
so Harvey Weinstein thank you very much
for that and not to be redundant but Rob
you're fantastic and thank you very much
for everything
Peggy I'd like to say I love you honey I
wish you were here with me but I know
you're right there in Toronto at
minimize having a wonderful time
Don Carboni I wish there were more
producers like you been and to my boom
man and my crew Dennis Bellingham and
Jason Lee Farley I love you too